so when you're worried about your kids  having too much desserts and too much  sugar I always knew there was trouble  when a kid would come over and say my  parents don't let me have sugar I knew I  would find that kid  huffing sugar I I just knew it I knew  beware the kid  who tells you the parents quote what  don't let him have sugar  keep your eye on that kid by the way  you're so right you're so right because  my mom wouldn't let me eat sugar Studio  54. but no sugar we eat an alcohol  totally fine but don't touch that sugar  that makes perfect sense and I did I  snuck chocolate in the closet yes under  the bed for sure all the other habits  were out in the open but the sugar was  an in the closet thing oh yeah literally  I would hide it in a box in my closet  and just